更明白的女人是我想要什么东西，
什么东西对我最重要，
排在第一位，
那其他的东西的话，
我可以做妥协，
你想要什么？
我今年38岁，
我跟我爱人都是农村的，
我们是初中的同学，
我们结婚有12年好的孩子，
一个11岁，
一个5岁。
我们刚开始恋爱的时候是弟弟结婚之后过了半年我来到了他的同学，
就等于没有工作了，
跟他在一起。
他们那个时候准备结婚的时候是刚刚开始创业，
结婚之前是我的工资比他的高，
我们结婚的时候是没有彩礼，
没有三金，
就是什么都没有，
裸婚的。
当初我爸爸妈妈是不同意的，
我也是为了让爸爸妈妈放心，
我拿，
我就是自己存着几万块钱给我老公当做彩礼给我妈，
我妈也是当着他的面马上把这个几万块钱就是给我了，
他创业当了几万块钱之后，
我们用我的彩礼，
我们两个一起买了辆车，
两个人就特别的开心，
开车回老家了。
回到老家的时候，
他妈就跟我说，
因为我们结婚的时候是没有买房子，
但是我老公在家里面建了一点房子，
可能一共花了十几二十万吧，
她爸爸妈妈是没有存款的，
只出了2万块。
钱剩下的是我老公出的，
最后他可能外债还有2万块钱吧，
就是借房子的钱，
我们开车回去之后，
他说谁是谁家，
说我们还钱就没钱，
买车，
就有钱说给我听，
我那时候是小姑娘，
不懂这些，
他的潜台词，
我就说啊，
谁说的，
他说有人说呀，
回头想想哈，
他其实那不的是潜台词，
但是我不懂，
就是他俩在你俩结婚之前，
他们家是有债务的，
但是你不知道的是不是债务，
也就是做房子的这2万块钱，
其他的也没有，
就是说我们结婚的时候，
他和他家是什么都没有的，
过了半年之后，
我到这边一起创业了，
我们刚开始就是没有任何的投资，
小区里面的小房子在做，
做的还可以了，
对未来有前景了，
就打算到外面来做店面，
正式的做启动资金可能要十几万，
当时我爸给了10万给我们，
就说这个10万是不用还的给我的，
我们这样做起来了，
生了小孩第一年的话，
刚开始是他妈妈过来帮了三个月，
因为合不来就让他回去了，
回去了之后就是我全职在带关系呢，
时好时坏，
反正也会吵架，
可能我自己就是会有这种意识，
感觉向他要钱啊什么的，
好像心里没那么舒服，
但是他可能没有什么感觉。
然后我就一边带小孩一边做起了微商，
做了大概有两年吧，
也做到了一定的成绩，
公司也都有福利，
像父亲节啊，
他会发2000块钱给我们这个级别的人员给父亲买东西，
那当初我就没有给我爸爸买东西，
我是给他买了一副雷锋的眼镜，
有发票是可以拿到公司，
公司马上会转钱给我们的，
小事儿咱就不在直播间聊了啊，
咱重点是现在你遇到了什么矛盾了，
遇到了什么问题了，
自从买了一套房子之后，
他就一直想要把他爸爸妈妈接到这边来养老，
我是不同意嘛，
因为我们合不来的，
我们现在是买了两套房子，
他就提的更频繁了，
那我坚决不同意，
我问你现在你老公创业成功了吗？
一年能挣多少钱？
成功了？
前几年挣的多，
一年有一两百吧，
现在没有是吧？
对，
你现在还有赚钱的能力吗？
一起来跟他在一起做的，
一起做，
你客观的来讲，
这个生意缺你和缺他哪个影响生意更严重，
换过来讲，
这个生意谁是主导，
谁是辅助，
他是主导，
我是辅助，
你的这个工作如果在市场上换个人来干的话，
一个月能挣多少钱，
可能1万来块吧，
我为什么要这么问你啊，
姐妹啊，
其实你知道吗？
像你们这个。
夫妻关系你一旦想通了之后就是特别好过，
你要是想不通的话，
你俩必然会散伙，
什么意思呢？
因为在你的心里，
你始终是带着以前的那个眼镜在看他，
你始终觉得我当时嫁给你的时候，
你什么都没有，
我自己拿出彩礼钱来娶我自己，
我自己拿出钱来买了这辆车，
我来帮着你创业，
你才有今天。
你老站在这个角度的话，
是个男的都得跑，
是个男的都不希望别人知道自己是靠着女人占位的，
靠着女人的钱创业的，
没有哪个男的愿意向这个世界去承认这一点明白吗？
你现在需要做的是承认你老公蜕变了，
承认你老公优秀，
承认你老公有本事，
承认你老公他现在在社会竞争上取得的这些成就，
买了两套房，
把你和孩子养的很好，
你要转换身份，
转换角度去看待他，
对待他，
不然的话早晚得是对是太大的，
但是如果没有我，
他挣不了这么多，
我的工作是确实1万块钱的人可以做，
但是1万块钱的人来做这个工作的话，
那他的学校就不会发展的这么好，
赚不了这么多，
前段时间不是中秋节嘛，
他爸爸妈妈过来了，
今年年初过来的，
是做了我们另外一套房子，
我们是做这套房子，
中秋节前两天过来，
很凶猛的超。
我的门他是每天都会过来的，
他养完鸡在我们家院子里面，
每天上午来一次，
下午来一次，
那我的门从来都是没有上锁的，
他随时可以进来，
可能是小孩子玩哈，
把门给反锁了，
他开不了，
我早上回来做早餐的时候，
他看到我已经在下面了，
他就咚咚咚很大声音的敲门，
我就开门，
我说怎么啦，
他气气冲冲的进来跟我说不想哭就离，
那你现在想要问我什么问题吗？
他的观念就是我给我爸妈，
就是比如说给钱了和养老啊，
都是不应该的，
那是本身是儿子做多都要做的，
他有三个姐姐，
反正矛盾都是他三个姐姐也都在背后养养他，
意思就是，
呃，
娶了媳妇儿不要忘了你啊，
他是特别的大男子主义，
我们一起创业的，
那我手头里有一些钱，
他手头有钱，
他特别的不舒服，
他就说钱就应该男的管，
女的不应该拿钱，
你拿钱可以拿点小钱，
大头的都必须在男的那里，
你现在告诉我你手上有多少存款，
大概有什么资产是在你名下的好不好？
名下的话就是我们婚后有两套房，
都是我们两个人的名字，
有两辆车，
他一辆，
我一辆，
现在折算价格下来应该是差不多的，
我三十几万，
他的四五十万，
你手上有多少存款呢？
我这边的话是70万，
他那边我不知道有多少，
他的是比我的多，
因为我们。
前段时间也谈了离婚，
然后他就说钱各归各的，
因为我也很知道，
他特别看重钱，
特别算计钱，
那他知道我这边是70万，
他的话他肯定比这挣多，
所以他就说钱各归各的，
孩子一人一个，
房子也是一人一个嘛，
是吧，
房子因为价格是不一样的，
相差比较悬殊，
他就说折算下来他贷款都给我，
我是说我不要房子，
我要去另外地方生活，
那你想好了要跟他分开吗？
我其实是不想分开的，
就这样的状态，
给我买的孩子来说的话好一些，
你看啊，
姐妹，
咱们俩之间的关系算是有缘分，
但是你信任我，
愿意为我花钱，
愿意来我这儿买一个主意，
买一个分析，
是不是这样的关系，
对对，
既然你愿意花钱来我这儿买一个分析，
买一个客观的，
对这件事情的将来的一个判断，
那我告诉你啊，
你不想跟他分开，
我们就要承认这一点，
两个人的关系，
一旦有一个人想分开，
有一个人不想分开了，
那么我们的关系就已经处于一个上位者和下位者的关系了，
你一定要承认这一点，
现在随着年龄的增长，
随着他社会能力的增加，
随着他现在对自己的自信性的增加，
社会也验证了他的赚钱的本事，
他就是一个上位者，
我们就变成了一个下位者，
而不是像原来我刚开始。
嫁给他的时候，
我条件比你好，
我有存款，
我都不要你给我财力，
因为那个时候他还没有体现他的社会价值，
还没有那么多的社会经历和人际关系，
所以那个时候我是上位者，
他是下位者，
我不能一直以一种上位者的姿态来对待一个现在我已经是下位者，
他是上位者的这样一个伴侣关系了，
否则的话，
总有一天他会选择去起诉我，
离开我。
你明白这个龙飞表达的这个意思吗？
明白的，
那我也是跟他谈，
我说你现在要怎样，
他的意思就是他爸妈已经住过来了，
我的意思是你爸妈在这边养老可以的，
我们不住在一起，
任意一套房子，
他可以来我们家一楼，
也可以来院子里是不要上二楼，
他这一点不能接受，
我爸妈为什么不能上二楼，
不能来我的房间，
这个是他不同意的，
第二个就是他说今年分开住，
明年以后一定要住在一起，
第三个就是钱都要给他，
你想要什么姑娘，
我们通常情况下啊，
是这样的啊，
活的明白的女人是我想要什么东西，
什么东西对我最重要，
排在第一位，
那其他的东西的话，
我可以做妥协，
你想要什么？
第一，
你不想要跟他分开，
也就是说你还想要妻子这个身份，
第二，
你想要你的孩子有爹妈在身边，
有一个完整的家庭，
第三，
你想要。
己手上的钱在自己的手上，
这三点是不是最关键的？
我最关键的就是我想让孩子有一个完整的家好，
那你既然想要孩子有一个完整的家，
那其他所有的东西是不是都是我们可以付出的代价？
就像我们在市面上去买东西，
我今天想要买这个猪蹄儿，
我就得给猪蹄儿相应的代价，
对不对？
如果说我妥协了，
我让公公婆婆能上二楼了，
我老公就不作妖了，
她就不跟我离了，
我的孩子就有一个完整的家了，
未尝不可呀，
记住了啊，
很简单的道理，
我想要买这一斤猪蹄儿，
我就得付出相应的价格。
今天同样的道理，
你想要家庭是圆满的，
孩子有一个完整的家庭的，
你就得付出你的妥协，
我的妥协甚至并没有伤害到我的身体，
并没有伤害到我的钱，
只是允许他的爸爸妈妈上楼，
这有什么不可妥协的，
这个价格就相当于付的不是十块8块，
就付了个两毛三毛，
拎猪蹄儿就带回家了，
有什么付不起的，
这两毛三毛的。
还有就是这一年呢，
我们等于说是一个分居的状态，
不太说话的状态，
那这一年呢，
我就是白天不出去运动，
拉提力量瑜伽，
他可能就变成有时候在家里无聊，
以前那个状态，
他是因为他很满意能把控我的感觉，
现在我出去锻炼了，
我感觉我从内到外都已经有力量了，
感。
习上也没那么需要他了，
他就不想要这样的状态，
姐妹，
我们不要自欺欺人好不好？
在龙飞的面前，
在我们的直播间，
我们要袒露自己，
我们不要自欺欺人，
如果你通过练瑜伽，
你通过在外面锻炼，
你把自己变美了，
你今天就不会在这里说，
哎呀，
我不想这个加散，
你今天就会告诉龙菲姐，
哎呀，
我在外面我能找着更好的龙菲姐，
我怎么能够在这段婚姻里面能全身而退，
你明白这个逻辑吗？
我们不要自欺欺人，
现在你在这段感情里面，
你没有达到那个让她天天守着你，
让他天天追着你，
让他天天缠着你，
让他天天求着你不要离开的那个状态，
咱就不要演这样的大女主的人设，
本质上就是现在这段关系我是处于弱势了，
我想要维系这个家庭了，
我想要维系这段关系了，
那我就好好的去维系，
那我就想眷办法的去改善这段关系，
而不是演一个好像是他还离不开我，
演一个大女主，
你到最后的话你就拧巴了，
你既得不到你想要的，
那如果我们要分开的话，
他的意思是离婚不离家，
房子不用过户的话，
我们就这样在一起，
那有影响吗？
跟现在领证之前不离开有什么区别吗？
因为现在我们的房子可能可以卖八百九百嘛，
那现金他手上也没有，
我手上也没有给。
斩不了姐妹，
咱别东里榔头心意蹦槌的想反就是说我现在此时此刻面对我一个真实的心理诉求，
我真实的心理的愿望是什么？
我情感上其实也不需要他了，
我从身体的心里都已经比较抗拒他了，
也是为了孩子一个完整的家，
这样子的状态应该也是走不成远的。
不是姐妹，
如果你情感上心理上已经抗拒他了，
你现在就不会委屈，
你不会哽咽，
你不会难过，
只要你心里还是不甘心，
你心里还是不甘心，
说我以前条件这么好，
我以前在你那么穷的时候一无所有的时候，
哪怕我自己拿我自己的钱充当彩礼钱，
我都愿意嫁给你，
而你现在为什么不听我的了？
为什么家里我说了不算了，
为什么你现在就要让你的爸爸妈妈来，
明明知道我跟他俩关系不好，
为什么让你的爸妈来到我们的生活圈子里面去影响我俩的感情啊？
就是你心里真实的逻辑是这样，
我跟他说我就想能过一家四口好好的生活，
他说我们没有一家四口，
要么就是分开，
要么就是一家六口姐妹，
你听我的啊，
接下来你要做的事情是什么好不好？
接下来你要做的事情，
你今天跟我挂了麦了之后，
你就开始写日记，
最重要的是什么？
我想要的生活是什么样子的？
我愿意为我想要的生活付出到什么程度，
我愿意为我想要的生活付出什么样的？
在家，
如果我想要的生活就是一家四口的话，
那么我心里把我和我老公和我的孩子当成一家四口，
而另外那两位老人，
他们只是什么？
演员他们只是什么？
我为了这一家四口能够生活在一起，
我不得不应付的一个业余的群众演员这四口，
一家四口是我的亲人，
那两个人是什么呢？
NPC,
他为什么会存在呢？
就像我们打游戏一样，
所有的游戏他都要设置一个难度和关卡，
还有怪兽，
我们在打游戏的时候才会有成就感。
那在你的世界里面的我，
我老公，
我的两个孩子，
我们一家四口是真人，
其他所有人都是我要打这个游戏给我设置的关卡和NPC和演员，
我只需要表面上应付一下这些NPC，
表面上讲两句好听的话，
跟这些演员，
群众演员，
我就能保证我一家四口能够和和美美的生活在一起，
请问这样的代价我值不值得付出？
如果是实在不行的话，
你相信我啊，
姐妹，
你今天挂了我的麦了之后呢，
你天天连麦，
你就找那个情感主播，
甚至你可以找一些年纪大一点的主播，
为什么呢？
年纪大一点的主播他可以从老年人的角度来告诉你，
老年人的需求是什么，
老年人想要的是什么，
想要的就是面子，
想要的就是父亲节的时候送他一双鞋，
母亲节的时候送他一个围巾，
想要的时候就是周围的人都觉得儿媳妇对她还不错。
就你现在的经济条件，
是不是你一天花50块钱去连麦没有任何问题，
哪怕你一天花100块钱连麦，
你也花得起这个钱，
你从今天开始挂了龙飞的那个麦之后，
你就去做一个是写日记，
我想要的是什么，
我最想要的是什么，
我愿意为我想要的东西付出什么代价，
付出到什么程度的，
你每天都找人去连麦，
都把你的事儿来回说一遍，
去倾诉，
去调整，
去找到一个合适的跟公公婆婆相处的这样一个角度和逻辑，
一定能干成这事儿。
因为我们现在没有生活在一起，
就有特别多的矛盾，
生活在一起了肯定会有更多的矛盾。
我老公他现在不管这件事情的起因是什么，
他跟我已经是对立的了，
他任何事情都是站在他父母那边，
如果生活在一起，
大大小小的会有很多矛盾，
这样日子也是过不下去的，
等真到有一天日子过不下去了，
到分财产的时候，
你再花300块钱来问我啊，
怎么分这个财产，
你今天先按照我抓的这个药方，
先听话，
先去干好不好？
嗨，
嗯，
好，
就这样啊，
你看啊，
龙飞，
我干这个工作，
我要扒开所有的语言，
扒开所有的他表达的这些内容，
讲述的这些历史，
他这些过往，
我要全扒开了之后，
我要看到他这颗真心，
看到他心里面他到底住着一个什么样的人，
他心里面到底想渴望的是什么东西，
那我刚才连麦的这个姐妹，
我扒开了这些。
回你所描述的这些细节之外，
我看到你那颗真心了，
其实你不想这个家散，
你不想两口子散了，
你还想一家人和和美美的过日子，
那我就一切所有的言行都要围绕我的这个真心，
围绕我的这个目的去干，
是不是啊？
他现在为什么抗拒我，
为什么跟我挑刺儿去？
我就是因为我跟他爹妈关系不好吗？
我就是我不接纳他爹妈吗？
那我就能不能演一演，
我演一演，
我能接纳他爹妈，
我让他爹妈觉得我对他们还不错，
我演一演，
我让他爹妈觉得跟我生活在一起，
没有寄人篱下，
没有被嫌弃，
那他不就不挑我理儿，
不挑我刺儿了吗？
他不挑我理儿，
不挑我刺儿了之后，
我就一家四口不就能够和和美美过日子了吗？
记得点赞关注哦。